Cześć, mam na imię Katy Beslado,
jestem dyrektorem ds. strategii kwantowej IBM
i badań stosowanych. Chcę obalić
jak najwięcej mitów o obliczeniach kwantowych
w sześćdziesiąt sekund.
To absolutna prawda — komputery kwantowe są realne
i mamy urządzenia w chmurze IBM, do których każdy może uzyskać dostęp.
Tak, ale tylko do pewnych rzeczy, w których naprawdę dobrze sobie radzą —
super skomplikowana matematyka, na której opiera się wszechświat.
Ale jeśli chcesz robić arkusze kalkulacyjne i wysyłać e-maile, użyj
swojego PC.
Tak, teoretycznie, ale nie
przez jakiś czas — nikt jeszcze nie zbudował wystarczająco dobrego komputera, żeby to zrobić.
Na razie, w przewidywalnej przyszłości, jesteśmy na dobrej drodze,
a kiedy tam dotrzemy, zmienimy sposób, w jaki chronimy
informacje.
To całkowita nieprawda — komputery kwantowe
są fundamentalnie inne
i używają praw natury do przetwarzania informacji.
Dzisiejsze AI działa na zwykłych, klasycznych urządzeniach,
ale wierzymy, że w przyszłości będą ze sobą współpracować.
Nieprawda — mamy ogromny ekosystem
startupów, środowisk akademickich, laboratoriów narodowych i partnerów przemysłowych,
którzy korzystają z naszych urządzeń każdego dnia.
Nie — obliczenia kwantowo-inspirowane istnieją
od dawna i działają na klasycznych urządzeniach, nigdy nie
spełnią obietnicy obliczeń kwantowych.
Jeśli chcesz obliczeń kwantowych, musisz to robić na prawdziwych komputerach
kwantowych.